hey guys welcome back to brandy V
Rebecca I monster on our world again
today we're gonna be doing another one
of my guides but this time going going
to be for the new monster that just
released behemoth and Monster Hunter
world so let's get started so first up
as a brief introduction I'm going to be
covering how to get this quest to start
you must be HR 16 to start talk to be
serious hander lady and should we give
you a quest called the visitor of a new
world which is a star sex quest you'll
basically be defeating a cool yaku which
is incredibly tall afterwards report
back to the handler again and she will
be giving you a task called the
legendary beast which is a star nine and
still HR sixteen you have now finally
met behemoth but now you have to repel
him before he causes any damage to the
surrounding area after that's over
you'll be given another quest and now
you will officially be fighting and
defeating behemoth going over the
physiology report it says that Bohemia's
head and tail are going to be his weak
points with his tail horn and legs being
breakable and or severable you want to
be focusing mainly on the head but if
you're a sword user you can also be
focusing on the tail and also doing just
the right amount of damage for this
fight in terms of elements he's most
biggest - dragon with water and ice
being the second most and four elements
it's to star all across the board so
personally just stick with a dragon
weapon for the Laura I personally
recommend a temporal and a vitality
mantle no berries for when you get hit
by the thunderbolt move which we'll talk
about in a bit Mega Max and HM potions
as always with demon drugs and armor
skins as well and some life powder if
you want to help out your teammates if
you're playing in a group moving on and
we have finally have the move set and
one of the greatest things about
behemoth is that the move he's doing
appears on screen which is super helpful
for forgot the moves names and the first
one is meteor and it's one of his most
common and one of the simplest moves in
his moveset he would launch a meteor at
whoever is aggro - simply running in any
direction will beat out the meteor but
be wary because this is happen to me
multiple times where there's been two
three or even four meters that come down
from the sky I'm not entirely sure if
that's because nobody had the amenity on
him or we were just close to killing him
I have yet to test that out the next
move is called char bidis I believe but
it's basically the tornado they
basically what this move is going to be
is that he launches a tornado on your
location that does tons of damage a huge
tip is if you are attracted to it
whether you're a solo or in a group drop
whatever you're doing and go to the
outskirts of the area roughly around the
walls of the area that you're in this is
the tornado will stay a while while
fighting it's best to keep it out of
important areas around the area like I
said around
walls there's usually about three or
four of these tornadoes in play at once
so definitely keep that in mind so you
can easily run away from this just like
the meteor but do not Superman dive
because if you Superman dive once it
officially releases then you'll be
caught in the wind and take some
unnecessary damage the next move is
gonna be his lunging attack if you
happen to be far away he will lunge at
you if he jumps towards you simply
Superman dive in any direction and you
will be safe he also has a flop attack
where he basically jumps on his hind
legs and then just falls flat on the
floor but he mental sometimes do this
when a player is underneath him and he
will flatten them using the temporal
mantle we're running out of the area or
Superman jumping will do the trick but
be careful because if you're hit by this
you will be shaken from the tremors and
you'll most likely be vulnerable to the
next attack personally I didn't do the
testing but I'm not entirely sure if
tremor resistance does help with this so
let me know in the comments below if
that does next move is also his tail
swipe and behemoth will look to his
right when he swiped his tail but
there's also a chance of a 360 spin as
well so Superman diving will negate all
of the damage possible for this move
next up is the Thunderbolt move I talked
about earlier the lines of the
Thunderbolt go forward and then diagonal
all going away from him as seen on
screen now dodging by either not being
in the line of fire or like I said
Superman jumping which is obviously the
safest move in the game when the
Lightning appears on the ground and
you'll safely negate all the damage if
you do happen to be hit by this you will
get the thunder blight which is similar
to what Kieran will give you easily
chugging or eating a nova
easily eating a no bird will get rid of
this effect so do be aware cuz if you're
hit by the Thunderbolt again with the
Thunder blade it's gonna be doing lots
of damage to you next up is going to be
the meteor line as I call it and
basically he casts a line of meteors
towards who offered the player he has
aggro on Superman jumping if in danger
or running sideways from it will do the
trick for this move just like always and
in the final move he has the ecliptic
meteor or the huge insta faint move that
covers the entire area the only way to
dodge of this move is to hide behind the
meteors he leaves behind that's why in
this tutorial I tell you not to get
these smash because if he does this move
and there's no meteors left to hide
behind then you're basically dead find
the red tornado that he forms right next
to him and I hide behind the meteor at
the right angle so that the meteor is
between you in the tornado and you will
not die and take any damage from this
move as shown in the clip on-screen now
I've heard a lot of people talk about
that if guard up does help with this I
personally have not tested this out
myself I do not use weapons that have
guard up or is useful for that so if
anybody has used guard up and has dodged
just let me know in the comments
I'd love to know if that actually works
and then to Edwin some simple tips make
sure the tank of the group gains amenity
and does not lose it or faint it cuz
then it will go away then behemoth will
cause all of his moves on him along the
other players to focus on his weak
points and fight him without taking any
repercussions of damage weapons with
better defense capabilities gain
immunity faster such as charge blade
charge blades and basically anything
with a shield which may include the
shipment on the heavy Boggan as well
behemoths can be mounted as seen in the
clip and usually when you fight monsters
they can be mounted maybe two times
throughout the fight but we managed to
mount behemoths about five times
throughout our entire 35 minutes so I
don't know if there's some type of timer
or how this works but maybe there is no
type of repercussion or anything like
that so just go wild with the mounts if
you can and then lastly there's also two
big crystals and a huge crystal room
that can fall and land on him that does
some heavy damage I don't know if they
knock him out I personally have not
gotten able to knock him out from this
but it also does like 1,700 damage which
is very critical to killing him way
quicker and yeah that's going to be the
end of the video today guys as always if
I did for good a tip or a strategy that
you used during the fight and you wanted
to let me know just in case I forgot it
let me know in the comments below so all
fellow hunters can be caught up to date
with what and how did the fight
behemoths with that liked the view if
you do enjoy subscribe for new I cover
the solo guides and most guides of
monsters on Monster Hunter world
including this and then my past monsters
like Lou Nostrum Erica ghonte Diablos
cool to Roth all those monsters I have
guides for so if you are interested and
you are struggling with the view of
those then definitely consider checking
out those videos I also do the weekly
event quest every week and then tell you
guys if there's a new weapon how to get
that and all that good stuff so
definitely consider subscribing if that
sounds interesting my two most recent
videos would be on screen in a bit if
you guys want to check that out with
that guys so big rate is today
thank for watching the video and peace
out
[Music]
you
[Music]